- I, I have to say though, you
haven't revealed the gender
of your second baby yet.
- We revealed our first one on your show.
- I know. So I was wondering
if you'd do it again.
(laughs and claps)
- I was like, let's do
it again! - Tradition.
With Kelly Clarkson!
- I like it. I like it.
(crowd cheering)
I like it!
Okay, let's get a little, I'm so excited.
Okay. Let's get a little
help from our friend
from above, The voice of
God, because he knows things.
- God?
He knows these things.
Are you there, Lord?
(angelic music)
(laughing)
Okay.
- Why yes, I am Kelly.
(laughing)
Hello, Megan and Daryl.
- Hi. - Hi.
Or should I say Juni? I'm
sorry. I'm a big spy Kids fan.
(screams excitedly) (clapping)
Oh, I just love spy kids.
(laughing)
Oh, you were such a
cute little guy in that.
Fingers crossed for the reboot.
Anyway, sorry about that, Kelly.
- Fingers crossed. Here's the thing.
Actually, I wasn't gonna bring it up.
My kids are obsessed with it.
- Really!? - No way. - My
kids are obsessed with it.
- Well, we'll FaceTime, whenever. (laughs)
- I'm not kidding. Like, they would die.
They'd be like, you know him!?
Like, it's, like I'm not kidding.
So wait, so, so we were hoping
since you know, you know all.
- Right. - You could maybe
reveal the gender of,
of Megan and Daryl's second child.
- What am I having?
- Yes, I do know all.
I mean, I was there for the
conception. So, you know, not.
(laughing) - Okay. - Really?
- [Kelly] God knows all.
- Not in a weird way, not in a weird way.
I'm everywhere, you know? It is.
- I'm everywhere.
It is all about that
bass. So I would be happy.
(all laughing)
I would be happy to bless
this moment with my vast
and infinite knowledge.
Are y'all ready for this?
- [All] Yes. (crowd cheering)
- Okay. And the gender
of this child shall be,
(thunder crashes)
I'm sorry about that.
That's the wrong button.
I pressed the wrong button.
- Come on! (Kelly laughs)
- I'm sorry. - [Kelly] Wait, wait.
- You know what? You
know what? You know what?
Let, let's hear the gender
reveal from Big Brother Riley.
You know what, yeah.
- [Kelly] Let's do it!
- 3, 2, 1. It's a? - [Riley] It's a boy!
- [All] It's a boy! (laughing,
clapping and cheering)
- [Kelly] Oh my god!
- (screams excitedly) It's a boy!
- I love that Riley did it!